welcome to our session
this is a joint session between google
cloud and refinitive
one of the leading providers of
financial market data
this session is a great case study of
how bigquery
brings the speed and scale of cloud
computing
to financial market data we hear from
customers
the headache of managing on-premise
infrastructure to provide
fast access to petabytes worth of data
is a significant challenge
this is a case study of how we work with
refinitive
to deliver analysis-ready financial data
at scale
my name is tom salmon and i've been with
google for around three and a half
years in the uk financial services
business i've been working deeply with
refinative for the last 18 months to
help them take advantage of google cloud
and bring advantage to our mutual
customers
i'm going to hand over now to catalina
thank you tom great being here today my
name is catalina vasquez i head up the
historical data business at refinitive
we're constantly looking at solving some
of the most difficult problems our users
face
when accessing new data sets as well as
onboarding new sources that will be
relevant for workflows across the front
middle and back office we have been
working with google cloud
as they've provided a unique opportunity
to solve one of the largest challenges
our customers face
when dealing with large amounts of
historical pricing data
refinitive is one of the largest
providers of financial markets data and
infrastructure
we serve over 40 000 institutions and
approximately
operate in 190 countries we provide
leading
data and insights trading platforms and
open data and technology platforms
that connect the global financial
markets community in different ways
we help drive performance in trading
investment management
wealth management regulatory compliance
market data management
and also fighting financial crime our
tech history offering
sits at the core of key workflows for
quants
data scientists traders and compliance
functions
in this context let's pause for a second
and open up the conversation with one of
the largest challenges our customers
face when it comes to financial market
data
for every dollar spent on financial
market data a further
eight are spent in processing storing
and transforming that data before it can
be analyzed
so wouldn't it be great if we could help
change this we saw a great opportunity
to work together with google cloud
to solve this problem from the very
beginning we knew we were dealing with a
data set that would be petabytes worth
of data
so i'll take you down a short stroll
down memory lane to understand exactly
what tick history is
and how the history of tick history
started on the left you will see
that we're back in the year 1867 when
the first stock ticker was unveiled in
new york city
this revolutionized the stock market by
making prices available to investors
around the country
before that stock tickers were actually
travelling by mail or messenger after a
number of iterations
the celebrated thomas edison amongst a
few other inventors
patented an improved version of the
stock thicker it was indeed
one of the first inventions he managed
to monetize
the stock ticker was later replaced by a
computerized ticker with electronic
displays back in the 1960s
we now fast forward to 1969 and we can
see that
ticker tape is all across the streets of
chicago
people are welcoming apollo 11
astronauts back in the city
ticker tape was therefore not only just
used in financial markets
but also to celebrate important
milestones across the world
and finally our time machine takes us to
the year 1997
to a pub in london while internet access
was booming there was growing interest
to look at quantitative analysis for
trading
as well as process automation happening
in the trading workflows
algorithmic trading required increasing
volumes of data to create and test these
strategies
a group of academics finds out that we
have been storing ticker tapes in our
vaults for years
and wanted to access this archive of
every stock market transaction to
conduct some research
looking at market microstructure and
behavior
this is how tick history was then born
refinitive
collects the data arriving from markets
and sources around the world in
unstructured formats
we normalize standardize and enrich this
content to make it usable
so you can distinguish between a
government bond and a spot effects rate
despite the fact that every market and
data source uses different conventions
and different methods and describing
factors like instrument codes
timestamps location or currency codes as
an end user
you can consume the dataset in one
normalized and structured format
refinitive techhistory carries over 20
years of pricing data from over 500
exchanges and specialist data sets
this archive grows daily at a
significant rate
it's over five petabytes worth of data
compressed
and archived ready for you to consume
this requires
significant resources both to ensure
that you can keep up with the rate at
which new data points are generated
but also to make sure that you have the
right infrastructure required to deal
with such a large data volumes
think of the compute the storage and the
network costs
linked to doing this in-house so
going back to our initial problem
statement for every dollar spent in
market data
customers are spending an additional
eight without even getting the rate
the data ready to be analyzed we saw in
google cloud an opportunity to tackle
the largest challenge for historical
data
which is actually the etl process or
extract
transform and load process traditionally
this would be the customer's
responsibility
which meant each customer has to keep a
copy of the data set in-house
and had to allocate expensive resources
to unlock access to it
with bigquery we had the opportunity to
transform our offering
and move away from a download service to
now being able to offer
a managed tech history database allowing
our end users to access that single
source of truth
ready for query as and when you need it
so we stopped moving the data around
and provided access to the data where
the capability actually is
this drastically reduces timelines to
access the data
reduces the complexity in the process
and but also ensures that a single
source of truth
is accessible to unlock the right
opportunities
across financial services so
would you rather have your quants and
data scientists adding value to the
business
or cleaning aggregating and waiting for
data access
the reality is that most of the time
would traditionally be spent on cleaning
processing and transforming the data but
we can now shift
this 80 20 rule around we can ensure
that the business
gets what they want we can maximize the
time that data scientists
quants and end users spend on adding
value to the business
by providing timely access to the data
they need where they use it
to run machine learning models at scale
or build and backtest
new trading strategies we're already
seeing our customers
very happy about this we're able to
enable new workflows and also new
businesses to succeed
we're allowing them to focus on what
truly allows them to differentiate
in a highly competitive environment
so the single source of truth that tech
history provides
is used across a full trading lifecycle
it enables a more efficient allocation
of resources
across the organization from preventing
quants and data scientists
from sitting idle waiting for data
access to unnecessary infrastructure
spend
from the pre-trade activities that
quanta data scientists would perform
for alpha seeking such as designing and
back-testing new trading strategies
to the at and post-trade analysis that
would look to reduce slippage
or recreate order book analysis and then
finally
to fulfilling compliance and regulatory
requirements
around transaction cost analysis or
aggro conformance testing
one of the areas where we find
significant interest in leveraging tech
history and bigquery
is within the quant and data scientist
community tom
is now going to cover in a bit more
detail how we can enable
focus on alpha generation rather than
managing it infrastructure
so tom over to you so i'd like to dig a
little bit deeper
into the life of a quant using google
cloud
i use quant here interchangeably for
data scientists
data engineers and even traders that
code
really it's anyone that wants to get
insight from data
so i've broken this down to four
different pillars we have collecting and
transforming data
finding patterns training models and
then deploying those models
collecting and transforming that data
really has three different categories
the streaming data which might be up to
the second
real-time stock market data that's
coming in you might collect that through
services
like pub sub you might be collecting it
and transforming it using data flow
you could also stream it directly into
bigquery as well
bigquery here we're talking around
bigquery for storage
designed for exabytes worth of storage
which we'll talk about in more detail
later on
in this example refinitive tick history
is loaded and immediately available for
quick ring in bigquery
to complement this firms will bring
their own data
position data historical trading data
and maybe other
data sets that they have available to
them or they've curated and generated
in-house
where there isn't a structure to data we
consider that alternative data
you load that into google cloud storage
which is an object storage
and from here typically you want to find
patterns and quantize that data
they would use google cloud's ml
services for example the natural
language processing api
you can give it a pdf document and
extract the key terms and phrases and
numbers from that document
you could also take an image and process
that image
to understand the contents of it and to
understand what it's actually looking at
once you have these different data sets
that are stored and you've done the
transformation that you need to make it
available
we then move to the analysis phase to
find those patterns
so i've outlined three key tools that
people will typically use
at the top we have looker looker is our
visualization platform
for looking at very large amounts of
data and finding interesting patterns
through charts people might build
services like
heat maps they might be using this for
time series data to understand the
relationship between different data sets
to get deeper you'll be moving into
bigquery for the analysis phase
writing sql queries for advanced
analytics
alongside this you can also build
machine learning models directly inside
bigquery
bigquery ml extends sql syntax with an
ml specific syntax
allowing you to train models directly in
bigquery taking advantage of its
architecture which i'll explain more
deeply in future slides
thirdly we then have users that want to
write code
data scientists that want to use jupyter
notebooks or people that want to write
tensorflow models directly
they can spin up jupyter notebooks using
cloud ai hub
then cloud io hub has direct connections
and connectivity
into bigquery into google cloud storage
the key is this is a platform that's
horizontally integrated
you're not having to deal with
networking and connectivity and firewall
rules
all services have native connectivity to
each other
so now we've found some interesting
pattern or hypothesis
we want to go and train a model and back
test and validate what it looks like
so we then be moving to our third pillar
which is training models
so training those models underlying it
needs a large amount of compute
and we have different flavors available
for cpus you can access intel
skylight cpus and cascade lake and even
newer variants are always coming
available and these are in global data
centers around the world
for machine learning workloads commonly
people will use gpus
graphical processing units because they
significantly increase
the power available and reduce the
training time for machine learning
models
totally unique to google we have a third
level called tpus
tensor processing units which i pictured
here
tpus were designed and built by google
using custom silicon for our precise
needs for machine learning
to improve the accuracy of google search
results
to provide better recommendations for
youtube videos
we needed to significantly increase
through a step
change the price performance and power
performance beyond gpus to a new level
tpus gave us that ability and you can
rent
effectively some of the most powerful
supercomputers in the world
by accessing tpus so now you've trained
your model
you've done your back testing and your
validation you then need to deploy it to
make it useful
cloud ml engine allows you to take the
models that you've trained
through hpc computing you might have
trained them with tpus you might have
trained them inside bigquery
you can then turn them into an api you
can turn it into a restful endpoint
and it also has built-in batch features
so you can run batch predictions against
data that's in bigquery
or inside google cloud storage i'm now
going to go a bit deeper into bigquery
to tell you about the advantages of why
bigquery is the best platform for this
i'm going to focus slightly deeper into
bigquery now because i feel it's really
important
to underline the capabilities and what
makes it different the key headline
for bigquery is focus on insight not
infrastructure
google realized over the years that when
analysts have to think about the size of
the data warehouse and the amount of
capacity
they end up writing queries limited by
the infrastructure not limited by their
imagination
so what we do and the key innovation of
bigquery
is it's a serverless platform google
takes
care of the scaling the operations the
resiliency
it's a platform that you can load in
exabytes worth of data
and run petabyte scale queries over
hundreds of trillions of rows
and we automatically scale it and manage
it on your behalf
this means that when your quants want to
find interesting patterns
they don't have to make trade-offs as to
how much compute is available
and how many servers are being used
right now a key problem that we hear
from customers
is the team in london are okay during
the morning but then it comes to lunch
time when the new york team come online
and suddenly they get more competitive
towards the data warehouse
there's a fixed number of calls or a
fixed amount of disk
and then san francisco comes online and
they're further countries
and suddenly there's too many convenient
people computing for too few resources
and you end up with contention
and everything slows down and then you
revert back to the focus
is writing queries that fit the
infrastructure not queries add value
to your business underlying all of this
is the architectural difference around
bigquery we released a white paper on
the technology we call dremel inside
google that we developed 10 years ago
there's two key components of dremel on
the left hand side
is storage replicated distributed
storage with eleven nines of durability
we can store exabytes of data a hundred
percent of that is hot
online active and queryable it has the
same latency profile whether you're
querying data from an hour ago
or 15 years ago it's immediately
available for querying
the right hand side is a highly
available compute cluster
that we manage on behalf of our
customers
we make available a very large amount of
compute in multiple data centers around
the world
that can be span up on demand for each
particular query that comes in
in the middle linking this together is a
petabit scale
distributed memory tier very customized
low latency networking to link these
nodes together
what happens here is when a query comes
in
we analyze that query to work out the
exact right
size and shape of data warehouse needed
for that specific query at that specific
time
we know exactly where the data is how we
sliced it
sharded it partitioned it and indexed it
on your behalf
so we know how many machines we might
need to read that data in parallel
so we'll take a guess maybe it's a
hundred or a thousand to read the data
then we'll go through the different
phases in the query life cycle doing
grouping
aggregation and filtering more
dynamically
change the size of that cluster for you
to use the right amount of resources
to return the query as quickly as
possible
so this is automatic and this is managed
on your behalf
and every single user for every single
query
gets the experience as if a data
warehouse had been custom built for that
exact query every single time
and we spin this up virtually on the fly
for you
i'd like to talk briefly around the
shared responsibility model
where google cloud provides a benefit to
refinitive
who provides a benefit to our mutual
customers google cloud is externalizing
the infrastructure and data centers that
google has spent billions of dollars
building
we build and design our own physical
data centers
we build and design our own physical
servers and networking
and this is public and available some
great research out there for you to look
into
we take care of managing the physical
infrastructure on your behalf
and typically we see organizations
having two choices
they can consume infrastructure as a
service where they have access to
virtual machines in google cloud
they can take a third-party data
warehouse platform and they can spin it
up themselves
but the first question they need to ask
is how much storage do i make available
for my users
how much ram and compute do i provide
for my users
and ultimately you end up making a
trade-off do you build
a very large data warehouse and size it
for peak capacity
but end up running it when users aren't
accessing it or do you make it too small
such that there's too much contention
and users are fighting over a finite
number of resources
the difference with bigquery is we
manage that for you
bigquery is a serverless platform where
we run the software
the infrastructure the networking we
deal with the updates the operations and
the backup and everything
to ensure it's highly performant for
every user
refinitive have three core areas of
responsibility
data design that is designing the tables
and the layout of the data that users
interact with
data management getting the data into
bigquery
ensuring it's up to date and making sure
that it goes through the proper data
life cycle
and then finally access control sharing
the right data with the right end users
the final piece is customers their
responsibility is analyzing that data
getting the value that is their job to
extract from that data
so they don't have to think about
networking and cores and storage and the
etl process
they focus on doing their job i'm going
to hand back to catholic now to wrap us
up
thanks tom so as we've seen today it is
possible to access query ready data
without the need to store or manage a
real-time market data feed yourself
you can also leverage bigquery compute
and google cloud tools to analyze the
data
and not have to worry about provisioning
storage or compute
and finally you can also ensure that you
have access to an up-to-date
backed up and replicated data source
without the need for you to manage those
backups or disaster recovery instances
it's not just a matter of reducing the
additional eight dollars that are spent
on processing storing and transforming
the data
but it's also about reducing the time it
takes to enable
end users across your organization to
access the relevant data sets
and allow them to focus on where they
can really make a difference to your
business
whether that be the success of the
trading strategy
managing risk more effectively or
reducing costs of execution
so hope you enjoyed the session today
and from both of us
thanks very much for tuning in